il y a aucune raison de dire qu'on
n'aura pas l'argent pour s'occuper du
petit patrimoine jamais la société n'a
été aussi riche jamais on ne se trouvait
en moyen de pouvoir s'occuper du
patrimoine qu'aujourd'hui ce patrimoine
quantitativement n'est pas aussi
considérable que ça on sait qu'il existe
en France 40 à 50 000 églises elles ne
sont pas toutes intéressantes mais
admettons qu'elles ne soient toutes 40 à
50 000 églises ce n'est pas grand-chose
un édifice par commune plusieurs
édifices pour des communes de taille
plus importante c'est une question de
choix politique de choix budgétaire où
vais-je mettre l'argent est-ce que les
élus vont mettre de l'argent dans le
patrimoine ou pas